[Music]
the work of art therefore demands
another element of its existence
the god another mode of coming forth and
this
in which out of the depths of his
creative night he descends into the
opposite into
externality into the determination of
the thing which lacks self-consciousness
this higher element is language and
outer reality that is immediately
self-conscious
existence just as the individual
self-consciousness
is immediately present in language so it
is also immediately present as a
universal
infection the complete separation into
independent selves
is at the same time the fluidity and the
universally communicated unity of the
many selves
language is the soul existing
as soul the god therefore who has
language for the element of his shape is
the work of art that
is in its own self-inspired that
possesses immediately in its outer
existence the pure activity
which when it existed as a thing was in
contrast to it
in other words self-consciousness in the
objectification
of its essence abides immediately with
itself abiding thus with itself in its
essence
it is pure thought or the devotion
whose inwardness in the hymn has at the
same time an outer existence
it retains within itself the
individuality of self-consciousness
and this individuality is at the same
time heard
as a universal individuality that is
immediately present
devotion kindled in the manifold units
of self-consciousness
is conscious of its act as the act of
all alike and as
simple being spirit as this universal
self-consciousness of all
has its pure inwardness no less than the
being for others and the being for self
of the individuals
in a single unity
here in paragraph 710 we've now
hit a really important transition point
a transition point in terms of
medium or as hegel is going to term it
element and he's using this you know
transliterated term
elementa in german and the elements
that's a higher element a higher element
in the sense of
being more adequate to the
requirements of the work of art that is
a way in which
spirit through religion knows itself is
going to be
language right and it's not just
any old language or the fact that we are
linguistic beings it's going to be
determinate
modes of language as we're going to talk
about
in just a moment and in the next
paragraph as well when he brings in
a different kind of mode
use development of language in a
religious context
but this this movement this transition
to
language itself is incredibly
significative you know in a certain way
it's very
as we say very meta right meaning that
it applies to itself
because the entirety of the
phenomenology and all the work that
we've been doing and all the commentary
about it has been mediated
through language talking about the
statuary and the worker
and the crowd of people worshiping
within a temple that we're picturing
that
partly through imagination in our minds
right so there's some visual elements to
it
but it's linguistic we are communicating
about it we never
get away from language and for hegel
language and thought are intimately
connected with each other
now hegel does not have any sort of
overarching theory of language or a
treatise
on language as we might have hoped that
he would have put out
uh given how deep a thinker he is and
how many things he
he's you know talked about that will
come
with later thinkers um you know in the
19th and 20th centuries
uh you know he does have some
contemporaries who are very interested
in the nature of language but hegel
himself
just brings it in here and there but it
but it is very
important so he says the work of art
therefore
demands another element of its existence
and here he is using uh existence right
and existenti existandiren
in terms of uh how he's talking about
the different matters that are that are
coming to to our site
in phenomenology and
why why would we need a new
better more adequate higher element well
because we've reached a kind of
impasse we have effectively exhausted
what was available not just in the
visual work of art
but also in everything else that was
going
along with it the use of space
now we need something else and you know
you might think all the way back to
sense certainty right
what transcends perception and
spatiality and even temporarily
and puts them all into perspective
language we talk
so he goes on and he says the god needs
another mode of coming forth than this
than the statue right
coming forth her four gong um literally
you know
coming out there which out of the depths
of his creative
night he descends into the opposite the
opposite of
of what of of we might say of godhood
into externality into the determination
of the thing
which lacks self-consciousness
so what was the thing the statue right
and the statue could be treated
as if it's the locus of the god but it
doesn't
it doesn't speak to us it's not part of
our
distinctively human activity it stands
there kind of dumb
right and you know this is this is what
we
see in all the critiques of idolatry
back in ancient times oh you know what
good are your gods if we can pack them
up and take them somewhere and they
can't do anything about it
they can't even say help me i'm being
stolen
you know or anything like that so he
says
this higher element is language now
what's so special about language
well he tells us right here an outer
reality
that is immediately self-conscious
existence
isn't that an interesting way to talk
about it
so what is the outer reality well we're
experiencing it right now as i'm
speaking to you
and you're hearing me and perhaps you're
saying something as well
and maybe there's people in the
background talking at the same time that
you're trying to listen to this
all of those things are words they're
sounds carried by the air we can
represent them
you know and reproduce them in a variety
of ways we can write them down
as we have here in hegel's book as i
read you a passage
we are working with something that is
external
hegel himself has externalized
his mind into these pages
which are you know surviving him because
he's he's long since
dead he's been dead not quite two
centuries
uh you know but closer to two centuries
than
than one century uh and yet there's
something that that
lasts and that is this
higher element this is uh
as he says an outer reality that is
immediately self-conscious
existence now does that mean that the
words themselves
have a self-conscious existence no
nor do the letters nor do the paragraphs
nor even does the entirety of the book
so what has the self-conscious existence
in this case
well the language user right you and me
or you know whoever's talking in this
this paragraph whoever's being
represented including the god
the god is not only able to be
depicted through language but also to
participate in language as we're going
to see
in just a bit so this is quite important
outer reality
immediately self-conscious existence
right he goes on and he says
and now here we're going to get several
different sides of things um
just as the individual
self-consciousness
is immediately present in language well
let's pause on that
how is the individual self-consciousness
immediately un mediatedly you know
when mittelbar right is the the idea
there
how is it actually uh immediately or
immediately
present in language it says i it takes
positions
it enunciates it says things
it engages in a variety of linguistic
acts also in relation to other
self-consciousnesses like somebody says
oh it's a lovely day and somebody else
comes along and says no it's not
right that's immediate
self-consciousness in relation to
somebody else and you're like
jackass it's cloudy or something like
that and then the other person could say
oh
don't take it so hard right and they're
they're conveying
something to you that is partly about
you but is also coming out of their
self-consciousness and now there is all
sorts of mediation going on there of
course right
so this is to call this you know totally
immediate is a little bit false but
let's go on he says it's also
immediately present
now what an interesting turn of phrase
here right as
a universal so we've got our you know
individual
einstein you know versus universal
olga mine but universal what universal
infection universal
you know sharing something in common
when you infect somebody else
with a cold now you have something in
common
don't you i mean it's not something good
to have in common we can also talk about
like emotional infection
but language itself by its very
mimetic basis is
ineffective and we are always
infecting being infected at the same
time
i mean how did we learn the language
that we actually have
did we sit down and like you know get
the grammar book out
we're talking about our you know what we
often call our mother language or
original
language our primary language no we
learned it as
babies and then infants those who don't
speak
but just babble and then as toddlers
by other people talking around us and we
as we say picked it up
well how do we pick it up by being
infected
right and this is also going to hold for
religious language as well
so he goes on and he says the complete
separation into individual selves
is at the same time the fluidity and
universally
communicated unity of
many selves a community right
so he goes on and he says this is a
beautiful phrase
language is the soul existing
as soul zela right is is used twice in
that
passage he says uh alzheila existenda
right so it's soul through language
is more than just its psychic reality
it's tapped into a world of others and
this is very important for hegel right
that's part of what it means to be a
self-consciousness
is that you are aware of yourself as
a self an individual in relation to
many others and here hegel doesn't just
have it just be
one other but many of them and
who's in the middle of this the god
right so
he goes on any the next sentence the god
therefore who has
language for the element of his shape so
this is one of the modes of language
what does it mean to have language for
the element of his
shape his gestalt his you know being
it means that the god is talked about it
means that the god is
sung about it means that the god is
depicted
in a variety of ways i'm going to look
at an example
in just a moment so you know what does
this look like he says
the god is the work of art that is in
its own self inspired
that possesses immediately in its outer
existence the pure
activity which when it existed as a
thing
was in contrast to it language takes us
past this thingliness
in part because you know where is
language well it's in our heads it's in
the world it's in
our community it's in the god
and all of us are also in it
in ways different than statuary
and you know hegel's not thinking here
at all about
uh theories of language that would
reduce language down to
a mimicry of the world but he's blowing
that up right now
right so the wittgenstein of the
tractatus hegel has already refuted him
right here
or russell's logical atomism or so many
other
mistaken viewpoints on language this is
much more in line with somebody like say
heidegger or merlo ponti or other
phenomenologist coming later on
coming back to this he says
in other words self-consciousness in the
objective
objectification of its essence abides
immediately with itself this is very
important for hegel
abiding immediately with itself abiding
thus with itself in its essence
it is pure thought or the devotion whose
inwardness
now here's another important mode in the
hymn
has at the same time in outer existence
it retains within itself the
individuality of self-consciousness
this individuality is at the same time
heard
as a universal individuality that is
immediately
present so we've got both sides coming
together here in this and then he says
devotion kindled in the manifold units
manifold units would be on the side of
the many
who are part of the universal of
self-consciousness is conscious of its
act as the act of all
alike and his simple being so we have
the formation
of not just a bunch of individuals but
of a community
centered on the god and centered on the
devotion
through the medium of him
now what is a hymn if we're if we're
thinking in modern times we might say oh
well that's a religious song
and that's you know correct in a certain
way
it's not exactly what hegel has in mind
so i thought it could be good
to give you an example of a
homeric hymn which it means that it's
something attributed to homer or not
that homer actually wrote this but this
is
you know probably used liturgically in
some way
and there are so many of these some of
them are quite long some of them are
quite short
but i thought we would start with
looking at the one to athena
sense you know patroness of wisdom and
all those connections right but there's
plenty to artemis to demeter
hestia to apollo we could go on and on
and on
so here's the hymn i i begin to sing of
paulus athena the glorious goddess
bright-eyed inventive
unbending of heart
pure virgin savior of cities courageous
triogenia
tritogenia from his awful head why
zeus himself bare her a raid and warlike
arms of flashing gold
and awe seized all the gods as they
gazed but as
but athena sprang quickly from the
immortal head and stood before
zeus who holds the aegis shaking us a
sharp spear
great olympus began to reel horribly at
the might of the bright-eyed goddess
and earth round about cried fearfully
and the sea was moved and tossed with
dark waves
while foam burst forth suddenly the
bright son of hyperion
stopped his swift-footed horses a long
while until the maiden palace athena
had stripped the heavenly armor from her
immortal shoulders and why
zeus was glad and so hail to you
daughter of zeus who holds the aegis now
i will remember you
and another song as well
this is you know quite something what's
going on here in this
there's an invocation i begin to sing of
palace athena the glorious goddess
all these epithets right descriptive
things then we have some
drama taking place we have the famous
story of her coming out of zeus's
head that's been cleaved or cloven i'm
not sure
it's open and you know comes out
dressed in armor with her sharp spear
and then it ends by saying why zeus was
glad
so that brings that that narrative to a
conclusion and then
once again addressing the goddess hail
to you
daughter of zeus now i will remember you
in another song
as well and so this is a
bringing the god in this case the you
know
goddess athena into
a linguistic framework one that
i can read and then you can respond to
and which echoes other you know
other things that have been said and
which
could be appropriated and put into other
means this could be of course set to
music it is a kind of
poetry already right
you know in the greek it's got its own
sort of meter
to it and so this is a again a very
important transition point for
for hegel in what is happening so he
tells us that
devotion right is conscious of its act
as the act of all alike and as simple
being both of these sides at the same
time
spirit as this universal
self-consciousness of
all has its pure inwardness no less than
the being for others and the being for
self of the individuals spirit has
all of this in a single unity
centered through this element of
language
on the god
this language is distinct from another
language of the god which is not that of
universal
self-consciousness the oracle both the
god of the religions of art
and of the preceding religions is the
necessary
first form of the god's utterance for
the notion of the god
implies that he is the essence of both
nature and spirit
and therefore has not only natural but
spiritual existence
as well in so far as this moment
is at first merely implied in his notion
and not yet
realized in religion the language is for
the religious self-consciousness the
language of an
alien self-consciousness the
self-consciousness that is still alien
to its community is not yet immediately
present in the manner demanded by its
notion
the self is simple or unitary and
thereby
absolutely universal being for self but
the self
that is separated from the self
consciousness of the community
is at first only an individual self
the content of this its own and
individual language stems from the
universal determinateness
in which absolute spirit in general is
posited in
its religion thus the universal spirit
of the sunrise which is not yet
particularized its existence
utters equally simple and universal
statements about the divine
being the substantial content of which
is sublime and its simple truth
but on account of this universality at
the same time appears trivial
to the progressively developing
self-consciousnesses
in paragraph 711
hegel is telling us something
by way of contrast about what he's just
developed in the previous
paragraph where we saw that certain
kinds of
language can be the better the higher
element for spirit to help us
make sense of the gods of ourselves
through our community through language
and he's looking backwards now and
saying
so you know the language of the hymns
the language in which
the god is described takes on a shape a
gestalt
describes itself that is not the
language that we had
earlier of the oracle
right that's going to be different he
says this this language is distinct from
another language of the god
which is not that of universal
self-consciousness now looking at the
rest of this paragraph there is
something
universal about it but notice what he
says
this universality and the statements
that the oracle gives
are in some respect kind of trivial
they they don't have the adequacy
that these other types and those are
just scratching the surface because
we're going to see you know we're going
to talk about epic pretty soon and
other kinds of poetry that those provide
well why not
so now here he's saying listen we're
talking about something that
is involved in the other religions of
art so things in this section
and the religions prior to that in this
religion section what are those
the religions of nature where we take
you know crystalline objects or you know
shapes and plants and animals and
finally start making
artwork in in kind of a
more crude sense before we get to the
religions
of art and we might also think about the
religions that were talked about
at other places in the spirit section
and in the self-consciousness section
what
would be the religion of the
self-conscious section the that of the
unhappy consciousness right
so he's saying um the oracle
is the necessary no bendig
right first form of the god's utterance
and here miller's being a little
periphrastic
the first form of the god's utterance no
the first spraka the first
language that the god is spoken of
or speaks through you know presumably
the oracle is the oracle of
the god and he says the notion of the
god here's a really interesting
point the notion of the god the begin
the concept
implies that he is the
essence of both nature and spirit right
nature one geist um and he is the
essence the vasen
so he's you could say okay he's the
essence of both of these
in the sense that you know both are sort
of reflections of the god
that's actually probably the wrong way
to look at it instead think of
the god as straddling both
realms he is a in essence he's a being a
vason mason
has both of these senses who is both
natural and spiritual
and you know what is the goal here to to
overcome this uh
distinction so he says he has not only
natural but
spiritual existence spiritual existence
gestiga
existence means existence for us human
beings
you know what would be another example
of this sort of thing
what's freedom is freedom a natural
thing
a lot of people who try to reduce it to
something that can be figured in terms
of nature but no
spirit is a gestiga a spiritual
notion or experience or reality or
vision an essence so
he goes in so far as this moment is at
first merely implied
in his notion and not yet realized
that it brought forth in religion the
language
is what's the language the language of
the oracle
for the religious self-consciousness the
language of an
alien self-consciousness the god is
somebody alien to me somebody foreign
somebody perhaps even opposed to that i
i can't
really grasp or understand now where
have we encountered this before
unhappy consciousness right and in
other places in this religion section
and here he says something
that's that's really interesting he says
the self-consciousness that is still
alien to
its community who's that
that's the god the god is alien
to the god's own community of worshipers
of believers of those who are
talking about the god that god is in a
certain way okay
we could understand this in the sense
like rudolph
otto talked about god as being or the
divine as being holy
other this isn't quite that but the god
is
uncanny the god is not really fitting in
with us and the oracle has its
mysteriousness
as a result so he says
here we go the self-consciousness still
alien to its community
is not immediately present unmediatedly
present in the matter demanded by
its notion the self is simple or unitary
therefore absolutely
universal being for self now who's
who's the universal being for self here
we should ask
is it the god is it the single worshiper
is it the
community as such well then he says the
self that is separated from the
self-consciousness of the community
is at first only an individual self that
makes it sound as if the god
through the communication of the oracle
is actually an
individual and you know estranged or
foreign
self and it's the community that is the
universal being for
self and the god is kind of you know on
the outskirts bursting in
through the revelation of the divine but
not
really fitting in so he goes on and he
says
the content of this its own and
individual language
the language of the oracle the weirdness
of it right
stems from the universal determinateness
in which absolute spirit in general is
posited in its religion so we see
the universal coming back in now and
he says the universal spirit of the
sunrise which has not yet particularized
its existence
utters equally simple and universal
statements about the divine being
the substantial content of which is
sublime in its simple truth
but on account of this universality at
the same time appears
trivial to the progressively developing
self-consciousness so
you know a certain stage of religion the
god says
cool stuff that's universal about itself
about other gods about human nature
about whatever
and you know it seems it sounds really
interesting
but when you start pulling it apart
you're like yeah
i don't know that they're actually
communicating that much here
uh this this god who is you know at
a pythia or wherever else right
um what's actually being conveyed
the oracle is not really an
oracle in its language is not an
adequate
element for what's going on in religion
which is the development of
self-consciousness being conscious of
itself in
religion and so we get this kind of void
or what's what do we have here going
on past this as i mentioned at the
beginning of this
hegel is actually sort of casting a
backward glance
he's not saying that we move from you
know what's been discussed in paragraph
710 this new
mode of self-conscious language back to
the oracle
we're actually saying look how far we've
come the oracle's over here and that's
clearly not working
anymore for progressive
self-consciousness
now we've got this other kind over here
which is better more adequate to the
demands of spirit
you